[Music]
uh good afternoon nathan how can we help
hey um thanks for taking my call yeah um
so i have an interesting kind of
situation coming up here it's like a
financial crossroads you might say
okay so my parents are looking at
selling their house this year because
the market's nice and hot and they're
probably going to get the most premium
for the money on it
they want to give my wife and i 60 000
off of that sale
we currently have thirty five thousand
dollars in savings
and by the time we'd like to look at
buying next year
we should have between a hundred and ten
hundred twenty thousand dollars in cash
okay we just paid off all of our credit
card debt we're working on
getting the vehicles paid off we're
projected to have those paid off by the
end of the year
which just leaves my student loan
student loan is at 120
000 so we're going to hit a point where
we're going to have 120
000 in cash and 120 000 on student loans
pay off your loans pay off alone
i mean pay off dollars but i want you
that free you know
and i know nathan is not a popular thing
i know you're like oh my gosh man i
i could be i could be man i i can go no
no listen here man
how old are you and your wife so i'm 30
the
wife is 26. oh yeah so you're young so
what you think about this how much do
you all make in the household right now
last year we made 156 000 this year
we'll probably make about 175
and we both put in for promotion so next
year i think we're going to be
right at 200. okay cool
and you're in omaha what's what is the
average house goal for us like if you
went to go purchase a home today
um how much would it cost you like what
what's your dream
we're looking in the range of 200 to 300
000 so average i mean 225
250 okay and how long do you think it
would take you to save
up 20 of that
so that'd be about 50 000. so if we were
debt free today saving that up would
probably
be seven eight months yeah
all right so let's let's let's let's
dream here brother i want you to follow
me
you get this money from your mom from
your parents
you're gonna have about a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars right
if you already have thirty thousand
dollars you said thirty five thousand
dollars in your savings account right
now right
right okay immediately i'm going ahead
and just
dumping all of that into paying off your
debt now then when you sell the house
right i'm taking that money putting that
towards the debt
so if i'm hearing you correctly by the
end of by the beginning of next summer
you can be 100 debt free correct
yeah okay then by the end of next year
you can have 50 000
sitting in your savings account yeah
okay cool
so this means within the next two years
you could be into your home and the only
debt that you have
is a mortgage now here's what i'm saying
within the next two years because it's
going to take you one year to pay off
the debt
then i need you to spend at least three
months stacking up at least a
three-month emergency fund
okay then you need to go ahead and save
up that 20
so that way you can uh put down on that
then us
on top of the 20 you probably need to
stack up at least another 10k
for moving expenses and some extra
things to get into your home
so by the time you turn 32 years old and
by the time your wife turns 28
you can be 100 debt free home homeowner
millennials killing the gang
that is beautiful to me i would rather
do that than to rush into a home
and then i'm still bound in debt nah man
i want you to get into the home have
freedom have peace enjoy your wife
enjoy your life y'all can get out there
and just have the financial peace and
you wake up on the first of the month
and the only thing you have to pay for
is your mortgage
utilities and insurance bills and eat
that's it
that's it that's peace man
and then from there here's the thing
nathan
i want you to get into that thing
15-year fixed rate and when you get
there man i want you to attack this
mortgage
can you imagine being 100 debt free
on path to being a multi-millionaire by
the time you turn 45 years old
yeah that's what i'm looking at that's
what i'd like to do that's
it no no no don't say that's what you
like to do
say that's what you will be doing think
about it your wife
come on now let's let's be real man can
can i be real with you nathan i only got
like 30 seconds can i be real with you
ladies love financial security let's
just be honest
okay but they love it you know when
you're a man when you're leading
you know when y'all are leading together
when you're providing
you know financial security emotional
security white ladies love that
so go ahead and pay off the debt and the
man when y'all pay off that house man
take her to wherever she want to go say
baby girl where do you want to go
wherever she says she want to go take
her if it costs you 10 grand you take
her there
okay i'm telling you right now that's if
i'm in your shoes
that's what i'm doing i'm doing that
right
there man i'm excited for you man
we good nathan yeah that sounds good
all right man it's a big pill to swallow
you know but i guess you just gotta rip
that band-aid off and get it done hey
man listen here
successful people do what unsuccessful
people are not willing to do
nothing extraordinary happens within
side of people's comfort zone
it's going to be uncomfortable but
that's what you're here for
to be uncomfortable so you can be
successful don't allow your comfort zone
to become your kill zone
don't allow what's comfortable to you to
kill your dreams and your goals
and your vision nah step outside of your
comfort zone
be uncomfortable for the next two years
in the next 15 years
you're gonna be amazing you're gonna
love it you're gonna love it